how does it feel to be here on the go
below red carpet it's great you know I'm
been here before so to be here it's
exciting and to be here with work that
people are excited to see it's cool yeah
you've been in a lot of good movies I
think maybe you have the magic touch
what is it I don't know you know it's
been a good year it's been nice and busy
just trying to being part of things that
people want to see and that you're enjoy
being a part of so the fact that that's
happened with three four movies is great
keeps you busy you have a dream person
that you would like to work with from
tonight I like Paul Thomas Anderson a
lot I don't think he's here but poor
Thomas Anderson as a director like that
I could I could stand a long time give
you a whole list I think he's pretty
amazing
would there ever be a chance that take
those down some acting - because you
guys are gonna take yours done some
acting - yeah you guys would ever do
anything together it's no plan at the
moment but who knows I know
enjoy yourself thank you have a good
time
[Music]
[Applause]